beim neuen video ich habe heute wieder
zwei special guest einmal michael
hofmann vor wie du ganz kurz vor haben
die spitzen alle nicht wundern wir haben
dafür unseren kanal eine fußball kennen
viele geräte mit sahne halle zusammen
die flach willst challenge die puls also
solche die wie die anderswo ein bisschen
erkunden ich habe die jungs nur noch
gefragt ob wir das auch machen dürfen
wir sind ja cool mit dem an der stelle %
euch dank eine idee und das wetter
bietet sich perfekt an dass wir das als
auch ich habe gordon noch ganz viele
neue willst du mir mal zerbrochen dann
handy hier und ich muss sagen ich spiele
das gegen roma so erster witz ich wette
einer von euch schlacht in fünf sekunden
5 4 3 2 1
okay wir jetzt welchem arzt geht
pinocchio zum holz nasen ohren achten
was in kürzester zeit in kürze witz
aller zeiten
brennholz verläuft genau hier auf meine
hose ok vor allem hits wie nennt man
einen mann der schafe schlägt einen
mähdrescher gehst du von deinem album
zwilling hast was wir drauf kommt ein
bachelor bisse promo egal wie viele cds
du von unserem album swing hast ben hat
mercedes der war gar nicht so lustig der
war gar nicht so lustig er war nicht so
lustig aber das album mit geld bekommt
ist album nämlich also ich hab gestern
high court - hinzu gezeigt und bali da
kann ich auch schon morgen kommen noch
ein blog oder gestern schon da war auch
einen ausschnitt euro die aufgetreten
sind bei der video preis bringen könnt
euch das album gerne kaufen kann
gefallen ganz ehrlich es ging es sind
auf jeden fall drei liter bei der
kontron drop und der ist echt krass also
der ist gut so auch da geht es uns
vorgestellt
hier werde jetzt polizei bittet
autofahrer an
haben sie etwas getrunken habt
angeschubst nur polizist dann haben sie
bestimmt 19 kamille
ist schlecht die kurse im auge haben sie
1 wagen japanisch bist du denn wild
ein frau stück durch den laden verkäufer
fragen was wollen sie frisch sagt
der name von einem ritter oder 0 zu tun
die meisten unfälle entstehen in den
eigenen vier wänden zum beispiel wenn
die katze des rechts überholt ohne zu
beten
es läuft einfach gerade so schön durch
meine unterhose
ich weiß was das kostet geld bitte keine
moral sprüche ziel ist das was mit
diesem video kann man heiko man haben
jetzt mal anständig zu acronis ist
wasser 20 gefallen hat dann ist genau
jetzt noch nach oben oder sonst wer
gestern wieder mit dem alles auch ein
video gedreht ist sie irgendwo für lync
und die band uns ja wenn unser album
hersteller nicht vorbestellt habt dann
macht das gerne bestand ganz ganz viel
zeit investiert und es gab dem alles ihm
gefällt die musik auch und bald
gebraucht die erste jährige
lieblingslied freunde und belastung geht
nach hause weil ich will jetzt meine
sachen abonniert wie haltbar